[Musique]
altia rage de du afps chef de bureau à
tahoua bonsoir alec castonguay des gens
l actualité bien sûr et christian dufour
bonsoir à vous trois comme si on tombait
de notre chaise parce que ça fait depuis
cet été qu'on parle de climat toxique
cib ici d'abord en sortir les nouvelles
ce matin dans le globe
on disait que le rapport qu'il devait
vérifier si tous les témoignages
recueillis par ci bissière du canada et
est vrai par un master accablant altia
rage elle n'avait pas d'autre choix que
de quitter la gouverneure générale mais
pas vraiment non
c'est très vite et de la faire renvoyer
c'était vraiment la seule option carton
salle est il de notre envoyée il ya
moins d'une heure sans vraiment envoyer
la balle au bureau du secrétaire de la
gouverneure générale avril orange comme
telle elle n'assume pas la
responsabilité pour les problèmes
elle semble suggérer que ça se passait
dans le bureau de cinq secrétaires
fédéraux on va relire ensemble parce que
c'est c'est pas un détail ce qui n'était
pas avec nous avez-vous henri gil les
extraits du communiqué de madame payet
où elle dit d'abord toute personne a
droit un environnement de travail sain
et sécuritaire à tout moment et en
toutes circonstances ça c'est bon tout
ça est d'accord avec ça il semble
ajoutent elles il semble quand on dit il
semble a laissé entendre que elle
n'aurait pas été consciente du dd
dérapage il semble que cela n'ait pas
toujours été le cas au bureau du
secrétaire du gouverneur général
des tensions sont apparues à rideau hall
au cours des derniers mois et j'en suis
désolé
hélas la joute bien qu'aucune plainte
officielle ou griefs officielle n'a été
formulée je prends toutes ces
allégations
au sérieux et là continue pour le bien
du pays et cetera et cetera et
l'intégrité de la fonction je m'en vais
autrement dit c'est pas une folle qu'on
fait c'est pas une confession il ne dit
pas je m'excuse j'ai j'ai pété les
plombs j'ai été trop dur envers untel ou
unetelle peinture j'ai marqué à la tâche
exactement
puis il semblerait qu'il y ait fait deux
raisons pourquoi y ait plainte
officielle que c'était la secrétaire en
fait qui est en charge des pentes
officielle et puis que c'est pas aller
plus haut que la secrétaire et qu'elle
n'a pas commencé un processus formel
alors c'est peut-être une des
suggestions leurs suggestions c'est
qu'il semblerait que personne les
employés a vu de rome non ça crie
avantages du bureau du secteur d'un
crédit public le je me souviens plus
exactement meilleur bureau fédéral qui
s'occupe de recevoir des plaintes
officielles de bureaucrates et puis que
possiblement les personnes qui étaient
ce processus là non plus mais c'est
intéressant quelqu es temps nous
estimons salaf que ce moment si bien
c'est assez fortune parce que son frère
va bien la famille a besoin des gens
raison pourquoi aucun de faire avancer
je m'excuse j'ai ma gratte bon alec est
ce que d'après vous le rapport parce
qu'on l'a pas vu le rapport
je devais parler monsieur leblanc me
ferais mais ne peut pas nous parler on
n'est pas vrai une autre fois nommé le
rapport le pauvre le palu est ce que
d'après vous le rapport et s y est
tellement évident monsieur trudeau on
lui a dit écoutez là je peux pas faire
autrement que que de vous laisser partir
ouais on n'a pas la teneur de la
conversation privée entre madame payette
et justin trudeau hier soir mais ça
devait pas être une tape dans le dos
d'encouragement que justin trudeau lui a
donné probablement que le rapport était
suffisamment clair pour qui ce qui est à
peu près aucun choix possible pour
madame payette et vous savez l'acte de
contrition n'est clairement pas dans les
habitudes de madame payette et le
problème c'est qu'elle a un parcours
comme administratrice qui est déjà un
peu jalonnée de problèmes de relations
de travail lorsqu'elle était au centre
des sciences de montréal entre 2013 et
elle avait eu des plaines contre elle
sur le climat de travail et lorsqu'elle
était au comité olympique canadien aussi
en 2007 elle a quitté et il y avait deux
enquêtes internes en cours sur ces
agissements au comité olympique canadien
ça pose des questions sur les
vérifications qu'on a fait avant de la
nommer l époque en 2010 c'est parce
qu'on a pu tourner les coins ronds parce
que le prestige de madame payette était
très bien vu au bureau du premier
ministre
mais c'est clair que lorsque vous avez
un parcours comme celui là et quand j
s'ajoute un rapport commandé par le
gouvernement qui semble-t-il assez clair
madame moment donné il ya des limites à
défendre quelqu'un à laon on lui a dit
ou bien tu démissionnes je vais demander
à la reine de te démettre de ses
fonctions
elle a bien fait je pense de
démissionner dans ses seins parce que
techniquement c'est la reine la démettre
et non pas le premier minis passé elle
le chef d'état au canada crise hier
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire tout ça je
pense qu'en démissionnant tout
supplément lève quand même une épine du
pied de juste et plus tôt parce qu'elle
aurait pu traîner un peu quand même
moi ce que ça mais cela c'est bon
débarras elle part en fait de façon pas
très noble en évitant encore le problème
le rapport semblent accablants toutes
les informations en fait qui fuit donc
elle n'était pas à faire le travail que
les mêmes passeurs que des appuis très
criants mais si on peut dans notre
politique parce que les honneurs général
rappelons-le a pas vraiment de pouvoir
c'est un travail de représentation dont
l'âge est important il faut être
au-dessus de la mêlée
ça met quand même en cause le premier
justin trudeau parce que deux premiers
ministres précédents stephen harper
avait créé un comité consultatif pour ce
genre de domination là or lorsque
monsieur trudeau a eu à nommer madame
payet il a pas demandé l'avis du comité
consultatif et c'est vraiment son choix
à lui donc thomas qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'on n'a pas fait cette enquête
qui a permis de redonner cas c'était
quelqu'un qui avait de personnalité sa
possible caractériel et en fait si je
peux me permettre une impression
personnelle
ces derniers temps de beaucoup choisi
des vedettes comme gouverneure générale
michaëlle jean adrien plaque scène de
julie payette et vedette ça des bons
côtés mais ça peut avoir des mauvais
côtés pour conviendrait pas des bons
vieux position politicienne je pense à
jaime sauver ce genre de choses là parce
que vraiment c'est autant est descendu
jusqu'à sa mort oui quelqu'un me posez
la question c'est ça c'est ça allait
qu'est une pension à vie je crois oui
oui mais pas certaine si en démissionne
c'est quoi les règlements autour de deux
choses figées j'imagine qu'elle a encore
droit à la pension
bon comme c'est la première fois qu'un
gouverneur général démissionnons c'est
roméo leblanc le père de
dominic leblanc avec qui tu es aussi
mais c'était des problèmes de santé il
est vraiment il était très malade et il
avait mais sinon il n'y a pas eu de
démission
bon question on le terrain politique
comme dit christian est ce que monsieur
trudeau doit altéra joue selon vous va
se presser plus haut plus vite parce que
dans l'intérim ses juges en chef de la
cour suprême qui s'occupe de ça où il va
prendre son aux tables il va peut-être
même formé un comité puis va être plus
prudent altière je ne sais pas la
réponse parce que je n'ai pas encore
posé mais je crois qu'il va prendre son
temps
alors que si l'on regarde son bilan avec
des gens qui ne connaissent pas vraiment
le processus engagé à tahoua madame
payet il sait il ya voulu nommer des
gens pour l'image que saleh projeté puis
c'était tout
déjà ce sont tous des fans ils lui ont
nui d'une manière pour plusieurs raisons
qui est bien des gens qui vont être
d'accord de la manière dont chacun
extremis estivale mais un cd déjà il
n'était pas habitué à travailler en gros
en phase avec les deux femmes que j'ai
une amie qui s'appelle ministre qui m'a
dit ça y est je crois qu'elle ne
connaissait pas le rôle qu'on lui
suggérer elle ne semblait pas savoir
c'était quoi qu'elle devait faire parce
que quand on lit tous les missions
qu'elle avait avec la grc avec son
bureau les choses qu'elle voulait pas
parler sur thème voulait fermer elle
voulait pas personne ne dise quoi faire
c'est quand même on croit voir une
personne qui ne tue c'est pour ce coin
bureau de la gouverneure générale et je
pense que j'ai plusieurs fois qu'ils ont
suggéré que des jackson enfant d'un an
général devrait revenir je pense pas que
ça va arriver mais c'est vrai que notre
genre ils savent c'est quoi la position
c'est pas les attentes
il est mort j'espère que ça se peut qu'à
une élection au printemps
il faudrait vraiment avoir une bernard
en place allait demander la permission
bernard général pour on a eu comme que
monsieur trudeau dans les dernières
minutes je vous fais lire ça tous les
employés du gouvernement écrite ils ont
le droit de travailler dans un milieu
sain et sécuritaire et nous prendrons
toujours cette question très au sérieux
l'annoncé d'aujourd'hui représente une
occasion de renouveler l'équipe de
direction aride orale dans le but de
répondre aux préoccupations concernant
le milieu de travail que des employés
ont soulevé pendant l'examen bon lui
reconnaît qu'il y avait un vrai problème
pour l'instant le juge en chef du canada
remplira les fonctions de gouverneur
général de façon intérimaire c'est prévu
et une recommandation concernant
remplaçant sera présenté à sa majesté la
reine elizabeth ii et annoncés en temps
voulu avec ça vous dit quoi
il va peut-être pas se précipiter il va
bien parce que c'est intéressant ce que
dit elle tient et le symbole était beau
une femme qui est allé dans l'espace une
surdoué tout ça mais sa personnalité
manifestement n'allait pas avec le poste
non et si on vient un moment où le ou la
gouverneur générale le joue un rôle plus
que symbolique c'est lorsque des
gouvernements minoritaires
alors on est dans un cas actuellement où
il y a une utilité avoir un gouverneur
au gouverneur général parce qu'il
pardonne si jamais on perd la confiance
de la chambre
côté justin trudeau mais est-ce qu'on
renvoie les électeurs aux urnes ou est
ce que c'est le chef de l'opposition qui
peut former le gouvernement tester la
confiance de la chambre lyon et ont eu
un rôle à cette personnalité le qui en
général est effectivement plutôt
représentative alors je suis d'accord
avec un tir il peut bien prendre son
temps pour nommer la bonne personne mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire prendre son
temps si ça veut dire prendre quelques
semaines oui parce qu il va prendre
quelques mois parce qu'effectivement
cette personne là qui va être nommé va
avoir un rôle à court terme à jouer
et dans ce cas-ci bon on peut bien aller
voir le juge en chef de la cour suprême
pour déclencher une élection là mais à
moins qu'on modifie la constitution et
on décide d'avoir soudainement une
abolition de la monarchie
ça pourra quand même pas duré de manière
trop longue je pense entendre
gouvernement minoritaire
c'est perçu de façon très différente
elle tient aucun d'anglais que que au
québec
le rôle et la fonction de la gouverneure
générale parce que christian vous vous
seriez prêt à faire une république
demain matin à un des seuls québécois
qui d'admiration pour les seuls prix
tels extrait très minoritaire je vous
réserve pour la plupart des québécois
quittez la alors que dans le reste du
canada c'est une nuance et avec raison
et de souligner qu' un des moments où le
nom original pendant un rôle dans un
contexte de gouvernement minoritaire
très spécial mais moi je veux revenir
quand même sur ce que ce qui est ce que
dit elle tient au trop quand même
incroyable qu'on est nommé quelqu'un à
ce point là peu aptes à faire la job
c'est incroyable affaire le je dirai ce
que le gouverneur général c'est pas si
compliqué que ça de leur espèce c'est
quand même symboliquement important
comment ça ce sont les nomistes
personnes à mesurer le caractère de
madame payet manifestement personne à
mesurer comment quelqu'un qui veut
toujours la perfection à chaque minute
de la journée allait pouvoir s'intégrer
dans une équipe mais moi je peux faire
dans tigistes être dommage quand même sa
décision répond qu'il est riche et un
peu plus c'est ce que beaucoup de gens
mais on sait que juste après sa
nomination
surtout dans les médias anglais de paix
nouvelles qui sont sortis d'eux
200 dossiers criminels puis les
allégations factuelles puis ça lui
donnait vraiment mauvais goût parce que
t'es pas être battus et d'avoir la
fraise comme un adversaire
les astronautes c'est un petit peu comme
isolé pied conjointe que vous faites
référence à une fois que son ex
conjointe de viol et non c'était on va
prendre
résultat le meilleur comme journalistes
ont peut-être ces personnalités la féra
manque en fait les policiers et des
gendarmes qui sont pas de sa liberté du
jeune fille je pense que depuis ce
moment là et c'est comme si elle avait
comme autant qu'elle voulait miser
hommage plus intéressant cette position
me scie mais elle est décédée reste est
arrivé dans la salle est vraiment changé
la manière dont est le but la 2 qu'elle
devait alors les borgnes et au plein et
aux allégations accentué le climat
malsain parce que elle même se sentait
prisonnière de cet emploi là d'une
certaine façon la sentait pas bien
alec donc vous êtes nomination d'ici
quelques semaines
sinon ce qui est un prix politique à
payer lorsque monsieur trudeau où on va
ce qu'une impasse effaceur on va oublier
sa civic
bon je suis d'accord avec christian que
c'est son choix à justin trudeau qui
vaut effectivement devoir vivre avec
c'est la première
personne qui dans ce postulat qu'il
démissionne c'est pas très reluisant
ceci dit c'est quand même pas justin
trudeau qu'écrit le climat toxique
haridwar le moment donné quand même
demandé l' enquête externe
il a pris ça au sérieux le rapport
arrive il la pousse vers la sortie
sa peau ne savent pas prendre une
expression très québécois sap à
tataouine et lances à eau
on a quand même fait ça assez rapidement
alors non je pense pas qu'il ya plus
longtemps je pense que justin trudeau a
pas mal d'autres choses dans son
assiette à s'occuper que de gérer la
gouverneure générale donc j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas quelque chose
qui va lui coller très longtemps le
prochain par contre qu'ils vont être ou
la prochaine qui vont être choisis on va
s'attendre à ce qu'il ya un comité qui
est révisé son parcours est le choix
soit un petit peu plus solide avantage
ajouté que la première fois hélas là
quand il y aura de fait sur comment il
interagit parce que seul un emploi de
diplomatie ça c'est pas grave j'ai fait
une erreur on se reprendra au qui reste
deux minutes je vous entends tu sur un
autre sujet absolument altia alec écrit
c'est ce que monsieur trudeau doit
demain annoncé que les voyageurs qui
reviennent au pays devront faire une
quarantaine mais dans un hôtel et le
modèle de la nouvelle zélande dont on
parle depuis deux trois jours à leurs
frais est ce qu'on doit en tout cas plus
sévères altia je pense que l'année
dernière qui étudie
je pense que cela découragerait les gens
s'en vont
un hippie départ des voyages à
l'étranger à savoir que au retour ils
vont devoir payer alors troqué un séjour
dans un hôtel pendant deux semaines
parce qu'on sait très bien que c'est pas
tout le monde il reste à la maison
pendant quelques jours comme le
gouvernement le fait que jacques puis on
veut pas le les autres va rien alec
ouais je sais que ça va être annoncé
demain et 30 où les informations que je
vais être allé fait qu on est encore en
train d'étudier différents scénarios
qu'elle a peut-être pas de nous demain
mais écoutez commencé à interdire de
certains vols parce qu'ils sont jugés
non essentiels comme le sujet françois
legault on trouve que c'est un énorme
casse tête à ta voix comment on fait
pour choisir telle ou telle vol c'est
beaucoup plus simple de renforcer la
quarantaine le modèle australien ou
néo-zélandais effectivement été tu dis
là où on obligerait les gens restés à
l'hôtel
mettons que ça diminuerait les ardeurs
parce que ça commence à faire cher du
voyage le 6 fois plus incités à l'hôtel
point de ce même plus auront les moyens
christian qu'en pensez vous mais je
pense que le choc canadien est
fondamentalement bon dans la mesure où
la quarantaine est très sérieuse mais il
va falloir surveiller le respect des
justes dans la dynamique salutaire où on
s'assure que sérieuse où on est toutes
leurs jeunes dynamiques moralisatrice
moi j'appelle ça les puritains de la
souffrance solidaire où on veut punir
les quais les ex otages à l'étranger
si le gouvernement en fait dans ces
mesures montrent ce côté là je pense
avaient contesté devant les tribunaux
avec raison ça ne pas punir les
canadiens de talent à l'étranger d'avoir
exercé ce droit
j'aime entendre tous les points de vue
merci beaucoup d'être là christian avec
alter merci on se reparle a tout de
suite pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit